[Applause]
he will celebrate the 10th anniversary
of Ashoka reads Acharya at GPS with a
special this Sunday the two faces of Kim
jong-un Fareed Zakaria
[Applause]
[Music]
so ten years
congratulations time really flies just a
teenager when you started weren't you
and I am now I think I have now been in
every slot in this show yes well we'll
see how it goes tonight you know but
let's talk about this special first I
was watching it really interesting stuff
on North Korea it seemed like it started
out as something about two months ago
was it the the Trump impulsively said he
was gonna do this and we thought we made
deep D nuking the peninsula then it just
seemed like it was a dinner and now I
think it's just drinks isn't it it's
just kind of like let's just have a
drink and nothing too committed I think
even Donald Trump has realized this is
really complicated
the North Koreans began working on the
first site that is now part of the
nuclear program 56 years ago well they
have been working at this for 40 years
in earnest they have built in
extraordinary for this set of facilities
this the CIA estimates there are about a
hundred different sites remember we used
to talk with Iran that may have they may
have three or four they they may have a
hundred they've got sixty nuclear bomb
bombs at this point intercontinental
ballistic missiles and Trump says he's
going to do better than the Iran deal
which of course Iran had no nuclear
weapons they had to ship 98% of its
enriched uranium a away there were
cameras and inspectors in for 20 years
25 years in the mines he's going to do
better than that remember that has to be
the standard what but he was gonna give
us health care that was cheaper better
and covered everybody so it's you know
he's a Salesman but here's what here's
where I think the point you were making
earlier bill is is so important he is
going to get a deal if he gets a deal
that is going to be substantially worse
than the Iran deal yet he is going to
claim this is the best deal in the
history of the world and well you know
he deserves the Nobel Prize for it do
you think that the will anybody
understand
I don't know that s'what I don't get
he's supposed to be the great deal maker
no we had the Iran deal which was
basically you get your money back right
right it was damn money people there
must keep right
why didn't said it was we were just
giving them but it was their money that
we froze exactly they got that money
back right now what did they do for that
allowed the inspectors in now they have
the money back and the inspectors get
pulled out take that I ran well that's
the great deal well or think about you
know we have no new NAFTA we he said we
was gonna get out of the TPP and he was
going to do individual deals with all
these countries we're going to be even
better we don't have that yet people's
out of Paris we have nothing you know in
every one of these cases he promised he
was going to do a great deal even with
the congressional Democrats I can't
think of a single deal I mean the tax
cut was passed without the Democrats
he's he's never actually made a deal so
it's a deal breaker right I mean that's
really what he for so long we were able
to be the one country well not the one
country but the the main country with
nuclear weapons beside the Soviet Union
who was trying to get other people to
give up the nuclear weapons and we were
able to do that bigots it's kind of a
hypocritical stance you can't have what
we have because it was sort of assumed
in the world were the good people but
now I think a lot of these countries
Iran included look at us like why should
we give up what you have you're not the
good people anymore look who your
president is and and I think that there
you know the issue with the Europeans
comes in the Europeans are sort of
stunned to watch the United States that
created this post-war world after World
War Two a rule-based free trade open you
know the president of the United States
is now actively hostile to that idea so
much so that he will not sign a
statement with the European countries so
macros to say well we'll sign our own
statement and you're in this
extraordinary position now where the
Chancellor of Germany is a greater
proponent of human rights Liberty and
democracy than the President of the
United States who the thunk right I mean
that's a that's a strange world we're in
and I know you've been writing a lot
about Europe you were there in Italy
with Steve ban and I saw that interview
and Italy is just one of the countries
now that looks like they're going far to
the right and I think you accurately lay
a lot of this on immigration yeah
they have a different immigration
problem over there than we have in this
country I don't think we have much of an
immigration problem Europe it's a
different story and something like 55%
in the last poll of European countries
agreed that all further migration from
mainly Muslim countries should be
stopped that sounds like a Muslim band
that is above 50% in most of Europe you
know I think that the big difference is
the United States is a country based on
ideas on ideology
anyone can come in from you I mean you
look at us around this table we come
from everywhere and if you buy into the
American creed you can be an American
in Europe your your identity is blood
and soil it's it's it's all about the
fact that your grandparents and your
great-grandparents came from there
so it's you know that's what's so
charming about Europe you go to these
villages in Normandy and the same people
have been the butchers and the bakers
and it's wonderful now imagine you're
the algerian who comes into that village
what is the place for you in the world
and they just don't know how to
assimilate one of the ironies is in the
United States we do assimilation so well
and yet there are a lot of people on the
right who say let's copy the French
let's go be the way the German no no no
you don't want to copy them they're
there they are creating ghettos of
unassimilated people who will stay there
for generations I don't think I've ever
seen in America a woman wearing the full
beekeeper suit no exactly exactly even
though there's no big even though
there's no prohibition you can do
whatever you do whatever you get yeah in
a way you know they're kind of lucky to
live in a country where they're in the
minority because when you're in a
majority Muslim country there's a lot
more sometimes laws that you have to
wear something look I'll tell you in
America
assimilation works for the most part
there are you know some issues but it
works so well that as an immigrant I can
tell you my challenge with my children
is to have them maintain some small
piece of the old culture they just
become so American so fast that they you
know there's nothing there's nothing
left you're just desperately trying to
get them to hold on to a few words a
little bit of the food early you know
that's the power of the American
assimilation machine the European
countries look at that with one
they don't quite know how it works
because it's not a government program
it's a societal attitude this is a much
more open country